istanbul le mauvais sens et sophie des
mineurs et comme des crayons finement
taillée pour écrire sur un ciel de l'épi
lazuli pas d'erreur nous sommes là i
stand c'était dire à byzance ion byzance
antonion n'est as roma ou constantine à
2700 ans d'histoire ça vous altère un
peu 27 siècle de marche et combien
d'autres encore a traversé la chaussure
mérite bien les soins que lui prodigue
le cireur dans son atelier portatif
décor et comme intro et le promeneur qui
change de siècle en changeant brute aura
bien gagner dans un instant ces petites
heures de repos et de méditation
fumigènes au bout d'un narguilé alambic
roucoulant qui distille me dit on une
agréable saveurs de sillars la rose
pour le géographe la turquie appartient
aux balkans et l'asie antérieures pour
nombre de peuples d'europe et d'afrique
seul souvenir d'un empire pour le
diplomate c'est la gardienne des
détroits célèbre mâchoire géographique
surveiller du coin de l'oeil par toutes
les chancelleries du monde s l'europe s
l'asie
l'une et l'autre se regardent par thello
autour du bosphore le ferry boat des
temps nouveaux entretiens la
conversation
avant d'être incendié puis reconstruire
19e siècle le palais des sultans avait
été bâti sur un terrain reprises au
bosphore
d'où son nom de jardin rempli ici mort
le 10 novembre 1938 mustafa kemal
atatürk
celui là même qui a fait entrer sans
veine cérémonie d'une poigne de fer la
turquie ancien dans le monde moderne les
turcs honorent sa mémoire
ce qui ne les empêche pas l'inviter
périodiquement la turquie ancien à
reprendre du service sous les murs de la
forteresse verrou mini sar à des fins de
reconstitution historique où le pincer
répond à parlant à l'appel étouffé des
tambours
oh
le mans
o o
à
non
des combats simulés l arme blanche
mettre fin à l'évocation il arrive qu il
met également fin à la carrière des
danseurs de folklore militaire qui ne
réussissent pas toujours à se glisser
entre les arabesques tranchante du
cimetière et yatela on ne saurait mettre
trop de réalisme dans une reconstitution
il y a dans le monde 2 célèbre mosquée
bleue l'une à jérusalem et bleus à
l'extérieur à istanbul et les bleus à
l'intérieur les visiteurs les préfèrent
souvent à sainte sophie
les visiteurs ne savent pas toujours ce
que l' architecture doit talus lustres
basile de justinien ils ne savent
peut-être pas tous non plus que la ville
de pergame a donné son nom au père gamay
nous parchemin
mais aucun d'eux n'ignore ce que
l'histoire de l'art doit tout gène y ici
présents même quand il a laissé derrière
lui la sublime sobriété du parthénon
pour ce environné de quelques faits sont
romain ou de quelques grâces et
orientale
et ces rangées de fines colonnes
pareille à del valle de jeunes filles
décapité ses des briques pergame
éparpillés dans les cendres des siècles
retiennent encore quelque chose de la
lumière d'autrefois et qui venait de
l'esprit
en fait monument des pièces montées
humaine n'est pas le plus facile à bâtir
pour le défaire c'est plus simple il
suffit de retirer quelques pièces du rez
de chaussée
si la force des turcs n'est plus à
vanter la réputation de leur tapis n'est
plus à faire marco polo déjà sebei
cèdent leurs bottes
aujourd'hui encore les artisans refuse
d'employer des couleurs chimiques et
garde le secret des teintures naturelles
le marchand garde quelquefois de secrets
de ces étiquettes
souvenirs souvenirs voyage et s'est
acheté un souvenir emporté un tapis
s'accrocher un peu de vaisselle de
cuivre dans l'imagination faire marcher
le commerce
renouveler le mobilier de serre l
envoyer des cartes postales qui arrive
après vous remplir ces trous de mémoire
et vider ses poches voyager du côté
d'istanbul
c'est prendre le bateau passait d'europe
en asie et d'asie en europe entre deux
tasses de thé trempé dans l'azur du
bosphore
reculer pour mieux sauter les cieux
se glisser l'admirable paysage entre les
cimes bilson bissau
les monte ensuite en calèche se sécher
un peu au vent de la corne d'or
admirez comment les femmes s'habillaient
quand elle s'habille et comment elle
dansait gracieusement quand elle ne
savait qu'une danse
c'est enfin remonter en calèche remonter
en bateau par tim les voir se dissiper
rohaut loin dans la vapeur 2010 tout une
fortune au marbre et de paysages